you know how it is establishing a
startup at the end of the day it's a
huge risk and a gamble you're gambling
here on on a solution or an on on a
manifest or a this
uh that you have
and you know you hope that it will catch
or you have a you you you are the one or
i was the the biggest believer in it but
you know it takes time to convince other
people to uh that it's true
we had and i said it today
through this process
there was
perhaps 10
skills
20 30 the people that joined us along
the way and about 50 60 percent
pure luck
that's how it is
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders meet shiran weitzman co-founder
and ceo of shield he has over 20 years
of technology and management expertise
mainly in the financial services
vertical prior to shield shiran was the
head of sales at tm group managing the
company's major tier 1 bank accounts
chiron brings to shield many years as a
trusted advisor and a subject matter
expert in the financial compliance
market
in early 2018 chiran created shield a
regtech company specializing in
communications compliance with his
longtime friend of phil shabtai
shield is now 60 people spread across
israel london and new
york shiran weitzman welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you very much for
joining me i'm assuming from the shield
offices how are you
that's correct thank you i'm very well
looking forward looking forward to this
conversation i same feeling here with me
because i think that
you know the world is changing the world
is becoming more digital things are
flowing much quicker and if before
you had a person facilitating a
financial transaction or looking at
what's happening in the financial
markets
and having that inherent regulatory
spirit today things are going a little
bit haywire around the world and and
your company shield is dealing with
compliance and reg tech and financial
services and so
very very timely and appropriate
and the nice thing is that i know very
little about this i get to learn from
you for these 20 minutes so shilan thank
you very much for being here
thank you thank you so indeed indeed
it's uh the world is changing uh due to
the pandemic the change has been
accelerated as well
um but the world is changing things are
becoming much more digital uh where the
communication is in the center of this
uh
is in this
the center of this transformation and
i would say perhaps less in israel but
globally
communicating communicating with your
banker or communicating internally
within the bank is done
mostly via digital channels and
we establish shield about four years ago
with a goal to help their financial firm
to manage and mitigate
any risk out of the electronic
communications
what we do is we basically develop the
platform it's a workplace
compliance or workplace intelligent
compliance platform
that detects
basically captures
any sort of electronic communication
from any channels
manage the data and detects behavioral
anomalies and
a
behaviors right or behaviors and
anomalies within electronic
communication
uh
that
can lead to market manipulation or any
employee conduct give me give me an
example because it's a it sounds a
little theoretical but i'm sure there's
very practical use cases where these
things can come about
fantastic so two two examples right
first of all the first one can be front
running or something that the people may
know more insider dealing right inside
trading i know information on something
that i shouldn't share with you because
i am part of a deal
right i am participating in a deal i
know information i shouldn't expose it
outside but i am what i'm exposing it to
you you can do things with it you can
buy you can sell you can influence you
can earn
money out of it that's illegal that
market manipulation people can go to
prison
the bank that facilitated this or the
financial the financial firm where you
work can get a huge fine because of it
that's one example another example is
something less market manipulation more
in the world of conduct
um things like
colluding or a gifted entertainment
right
as a banker i am not allowed or as a my
my banker let's say my banker is not
allowed to get
gifts from me
right
not only that i'm not even allowed he's
not even allowed to get
me paid paying for lunch
according to the bylaws of the bank
right
why is that because it can be uh
during this conversation and during this
lunch or doing this event
or a night out
things can be
manipulative things can influence uh
transactions i can get benefits a lot of
things that can happen so therefore
these things are not allowed
um
today by the way um
there are there are new categories in
the world of conduct such as sexual
harassment
and bullying within the
electronic communication
that are starting to be very interesting
to firms to understand
how
how they move to
very remote and online
or hybrid workplace
is impacting
the
workplace behavior the behaviors of
their employees because you know
one of the one of the main
characteristics of what we do is that
when you are in the office or when you
are face to face
there is a
something that prevents
people not everyone by the way
of the people
are solid honest respectful etc we are
talking about this one percent maybe a
fraction of that
and um
what what characterizes that people
usually have a little bit more respect
when they are in an office when they are
in a face-to-face look my office here
everything is glasses right because we
believe in transparency right so people
don't do certain things in the office
right but what happens when everyone
work move to remote work
what happens when people are not there
so suddenly in our little world of a
little but you know very
very uh very chunky a
world of a capital market suddenly
traders moved to work from the you know
from the kitchen
and you know
even the people that are
it's it's a human thing it's a human
behavior even if you are
if you're not a criminal if you are not
a manipulative person
but suddenly you have a potential to do
things faster to shortcut the corner
right that's how we call it in hebrew i
shortcut the corner right i'm not
allowed to use my phone but suddenly i'm
using it because it's shorter to close
things rather than to wait and to send
an email right
but it's illegal for me to do that but
i'm doing that and then i am someone is
telling me some information but okay
write it to me and what's up then what's
up is not monitored things that are
easier to do when you are in the office
and oh sorry when you are at home but
when you're
when you will be in the office people
will see that you touch your iphone
this is this is on the other hand the
compliance officer the the the the
the
the the office police right the one that
i respect responsible for the for the
conduct and the in the market abuse they
also sit at home
walking looking at the computer and
looking at the screen and
there is no no one there so you know how
it is when no one is walking the floor
the cats are free
right that's the world where we are now
and it's relevant
very relevant
for market manipulation it's becoming
much more relevant for the
i would say healthy workplace things
like bullying sexual harassment and
other things that happens in workplace
it happens
full stop it happens people we just
suddenly we get record of it
uh so so these are things that
we are doing uh some of them are
mandated and regulated everything
related to capital market everything
related to financial firms are mandated
are must do by the firms and as we grow
and as people are moving to a much more
hybrid you know we we i guess we are
both members of this twitter and the
fintech in the twitter account and you
know people aren't you know no one will
will go back to a full uh working day in
the office for a full a week in the
office right 100 so uh this is the
reality and we need to handle the
reality so the amount of chatter
the amount of communication
the volume has grown dramatically
everything was you know switched to an
online
and online um
an online um facilitation definitely so
i want to ask you
s right before we i want to hear the
story of shield and then the founding
founding of shield but but a second
before that you were actually the
example of market manipulation insider
information information that that that
trends passes without it being you know
okay to but but it to me it sounds a
little bit subjective
that there is there a clear cut rule on
what sentences you are allowed to say
and what sentences you are not allowed
because i'm asking now in the context of
a technology that aims to
to help a chief compliance officer
maintain regulation in the organization
how can how do you go about leveraging
technology to help facilitate those
types of conversations
so it's a very good questions uh first
of all everything everything is
subjective in what we do even if it was
a transaction right
where transaction there are monitoring
capabilities that are a mathematical
rule but it's still it's a subjective
subjective element
um
eventually the
compliance officer who is buying this
solution he is the one that officially
signing it and approving it and is able
to
is able to also claim to the regulator
even if it will be the fca or the sec or
the cftc
i have reviewed it i i understand the
rules i understand the behavioral models
and i uh and i can defend it right this
is this is the life of this is the life
of compliance this is why by the way
they are earning a lot of money they
should be they should because they are
responsible for a lot of uh
for a lot of uh for many activities
there but
bottom line is that we are not
specifically looking at sentences or
word or that we we also but what we are
looking is we are looking on the context
and this
the sentiments
and overall uh behaviors behaviors are
not specifically driven from a word or a
sentence but from the position of the
person yes from the time of the day from
a lot of a lot of relevant
parameters that may lead to that and we
also have the history of the human of
this person we also know what is he is
allowed to do if someone is uh is um
if a person is a
i don't know an ethics trader right and
suddenly we see him doing many
activities in crypto
something is wrong
it's not that it's completely not
allowed but we need to understand there
is there is an anomaly here
and there are other things suddenly we
see people are doing a lot of a much
bigger transaction than they used to
suddenly we see people very active in a
specific channel and not on an a not
their normal channels of operations
something is happening
there is
there is a lot of there are a lot of
parameters there is a lot of um i would
say ai or nlp
a characteristic
that providing red line or red flags
or a
white flags in this sense to
many behaviors and that's
some of the things that we are looking
here and not the specific
the looking at words or sentences
it's an old-fashioned technology that
was looking into uh word spotting or
um
or
a detection based on
um very
very sub it's not a subjective but it's
very
um lacking the context that's the uh
that's the the words right the context
is very very very important if i'm
telling you now that i am resolving
market abuse
but you recorded it and you looking at
it then it will hit an alert in
an old-fashioned technology
what we are doing it would probably be
reduced the noise will be released and
noise is very very important to reduce
it because otherwise we are exhausting
the compliance team and the compliance
team is very expensive yeah one of our
goal is to reduce the cost or to
increase efficiency in the compliance
teams take me back to the founding of
shield
wow where how does you know your career
end up in the convergence of shield and
and what was the starting days
like starting days where we were in an
office perhaps
this size
uh three persons there um look we
maybe before that um
in my career when i was i was a software
developer i was a pre-sale i was doing
sales i was doing sales management i was
doing a lot of a lot of these things
before establishing shield i had i had
an advisory and advising a advisory firm
and one of the things that i was doing
that was helping financial firms to uh
to build complex solutions right one of
the challenges that i i once faced was
related to electronic communications
and
electronic communication compliance
and uh through the process that i went
by looking at the problem
but detailed review of the challenge
reviewing and selecting
vendors
in order to comply with the challenge or
to buy
to buy licenses
um
i understand that it's a it's an
old-fashioned it's we're talking about
old-fashioned vendors
trying to resolve uh the the the
challenges or news challenges that are
just about to increase we are talking
about 2014 by the way that i first
ran into this or
really looked into this 2013 2014
think about it teams wasn't available
even the slack was very early days a
whatsapp wasn't very uh
used um the electronic communication
domain was primarily email and the
bloomberg chat thompson registered voice
calls right this was the the the primary
channels
um
but we saw i saw we
you know iphone was becoming much more a
a much more
common
yeah common and spread and electronic
communications and the ease of instance
messages became much more a
much more clear
and i saw the trend on one hand on the
other hand i see that
firms
are looking into the problem as a point
solution right how can i resolve this
and this only no one was looking on the
or reviewing the complete challenge of
electronic communication compliance a to
z
end to end so we find out we found out
seeing uh platforms or swing solutions
by the way some of them are competitors
now that are doing only the capture
right so they have a
a lot of connectors or connector
capability to connect to the channels
that's it
and then you have a
custom vendors that can do
the data management and then there are
vendors that can do the analytics there
wasn't one that can do everything but
you know i was still it was a 2014 it
was still early days and i was buying
from one competitor it is and one
company i
shield wasn't existed there back then so
from one vendor and from one vendor and
then i started to implement it or we
started to implement it with this uh
with this bank
and it took us ages and every little
change every little
uh
a change in the format uh changing the
uh in the api was crashing the entire
solution it wasn't scalable it wasn't
but the problem
the problem was existing
so um
it was very expensive process for that
customer and very lengthy and that
triggered me to
to to understand that there is a real
problem here and allowed me to go
further into the rabbit hole and look
for
other regulations and other domains that
it may be relevant
and
you know how it is establishing a
startup at the end of the day it's a
huge risk and a gamble you're gambling
here on on a solution or an on on a
manifest or a thesa
that you have
and you know you hope that it will catch
or you have a you you you are the one or
i was the the biggest believer in it but
you know it takes time to convince other
people to uh that it's true
we had and i said it today
through this process
there was
perhaps 10 skills
20 30 the people that joined us along
the way and about 50 60 percent
pure luck
that's how it is
it is what it is
and uh you know you need to be like you
need to be in the right place in the
right time with the right with the right
amount of uh funding and the the right
team
so you know it's it's a it's a
it's a condensed luck or it's a it's a
lack that you help him be very lucky um
but
yeah
that's uh that's a that's the story if
you're if you're looking
into the future of shield because you're
mentioning here that there it's not just
you know what what you're discovering
until now but you're discovering that
this is a trend that is going to
continue growing and and it will go into
more domains where do you see shield
positioned within the market
so uh look we currently are working with
financial firms around
financial transactions and financial
advisors it's all around regulated
domains or regulated markets
but
we see electronic communication as an
infrastructure infrastructure for people
to communicate
to exchange ideas to do bad stuff to do
good stuff things will happen much more
digitally and what we want to see or the
the the way we see shield in the future
is um expanding into uh not only risk
platform but also an inside platform so
we will be able to help
not only financial firms but any firm
to mitigate the risk out of itself we
talked about it um sexual harassment or
any conduct right so to mitigate risk
but not only that to reveal insights
coming from internal and external
communication basically any type of
communication
so if you as um as a firm would like to
understand just as an example uh you
know esg now is a big thing right
so you have an esg targets right but you
want to understand as a firm
um how are your employees
compliant with the esg
policies that you uh
you throw out there or you announced
right
and
one method is to see what are the
solutions that they're offering to their
customers if it's a sales organization
if it's a support organization what are
the alternatives that they are offering
to their customers and
internally they are probably an internal
kpis that we are able to measure through
understanding of the email through
understanding of the voice conversation
through understanding of their internal
teams or slack communications
so any
risk on one hand
and insight on the other hand are of
interest for us and we believe that it
should be an enterprise enterprise-grade
platform
outside of financial firms as well
amazing shiran i i love this
conversation thank you very much for
for your time and for your energy this
was really really great and
and obviously i think shield is in a in
a very timely place and i love how
you're attributing you know both both
the skills and the team members but also
to find it in the right place in the
right time and i think that that's all
often a factor that we take for granted
when we think about you know success and
uh but but at the end it's all about
execution you know
even if there was the luck and you still
need a good execution in order to
uh
and i think that people are and one of
the things that is uh important for us
is that
we want to do essentially we want to do
good things right we don't want to um
we want to be able to influence um a
more transparent market it's a more
transparent workplace so the values that
are in the basis of the software that we
are creating are are are very positive
and we are very proud of it and that's
one of the things that uh
we would like to maintain as well
fantastic
thank you very much and stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you very much thank you
you